[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale télé
spéciale le sont pour des butins avec
nino maso manager bonjour ni notre genre
alors aujourd'hui je crois qu'on va
avoir deux parties quelques cantons
début taux d'échec il faut absolument
connaître avoir vu passer des parties
extraordinaire et qui en plus sont
représentatives de ce qu'il faut pas
faire dans les ouvertures
whissell sent très très belle partie
vouée au 19e siècle ce sont les bars et
très célèbre pratiquement pour le joueur
d'échecs le connaissent et les ont
présentées c'est absolument voir bien
débuté aux échecs il faut les connaître
je crois c'est sûr que tous les joueurs
qui apprennent à jouer aux échecs les
veulent progresser un petit peu doivent
connaître ces partis qu'on appelle lune
la toujours jeune l'autre qu'on appelle
l'immortel qui ont été joués toutes les
deux par un très grand joueur d'échecs
du 18ème siècle qui est en tersen wii
est qui qui sont à qui sont typiques des
heures d'ouverture et de la façon dont
on peut punir sévèrement un adversaire
qui bafoue un peu les principes
oui et donc
c'est bien de les connaître quand même
parce que déjà rien que vous voyez que
ça s'appelle immortel est urgent on
comprend que cette confiance comme
pourtant la connaître et d'ailleurs il
ya certes un entraîneur qui aime dire
que ça s'appelle immortel parce que ça a
immortalisé les fautes adverses à 6,1
pour avancer confesse mais en même temps
ils l'aiment bien montrer cette partie
aux élèves exactement pour immortaliser
alors on va voir cette deux parties on
va commencer par là c'est la toujours
jeune
d'abord on réattaque urgente voilà donc
verlan un différend 852 donc là c'est
l'inversé
voilà on retiendra le nom surtout
d'adolphe andersen septième joueur
allemand alors on y va
e4 e5 conversion typique atypique pour
l'instant donc normal et anderson
sortant camille attaque le pion central
le coup logique à faire un d'écologique
en tout cas le coup car les c6 qui
défend le pion peu 5 et plusieurs autres
coups possible évidemment poussé 4 et la
lune noire joue un coût tout à fait sain
c'est le couffo csn qui fait entrer dans
la partie italienne classique 1 winder
pourquoi on place les fous sur sa 4s et
san jose par la marque
le cube faible on peut dire d'autre part
cf cet hebdo parce qu'elles sont des
phases uniquement par le roi et c'est
pas forcément suffisant il peut y avoir
de sécurité issus du plan tarp
je suis donc c'est plus vous à contrôler
aussi que ce soit intéressant de placer
déjà les fausses attaques et
potentiellement les cas on attaque les
casses faible c'est aussi le cas central
contrôlé par blanc et pareil pour le sou
noir donc tous âges y est là donc
anderson jouen ce qu'on appelle en
gambie c'est à dire un sacrifice de
pions ce qui peut se jouer c'est tout à
fait voilà ça s'appelle le gang dit
evans qui est le coût des quatre voilà
on donne un pion avec l'idée en fait de
gagner du temps de développement
c'est ce qu'on a on dit dans d'autres le
sont des gonades tv vous invite à
regarder sur les odeurs typiques
d'ouverture on explique qu'un pion
l'ouverture ça vous en général trois
temps donc si on en récupère déjà 2
c'est facile de se dire que le pion et
sacrifient à bon escient donc la b4
c'est normal et les noirs prennent du
fou donc concrètement ces idées de
sécréter cette étoile dans ses positions
les blancs dans le plan faire c'est
capté 5 4 bonjour pour obtenir le centre
veut jouer 6 3 et des autres grâce à b4
il estime qu' ils vont faire ces trois
étaient 4 avec le tempo en attaquant le
fou voilà c'était de gagner du temps on
va pouvoir jouer ses trois des quatre en
gagnant du temps sur le et en plus en
plus grâce à ces sacrifices
ça libère toi tu te caser les diagonales
pour le fou et on sortir les pièces
beaucoup plus rapidement
qu'est-ce il n'a pas écrit que vous
allez voir tout ça bout même france et
quatre tuées ces trois attaques le cadre
vous recul ici et là des cadres des
quatre
donc là on n'a pas peur donc les leurs
menaces tout de suite doit être tout
simplement de prendre le 5 1 rien de
moins
les noirs prennent sur la classe des
quatre donc là ils perdent encore du
temps en prenant en fait donc les blancs
s'écrit et se crever pour ouvrir tôt et
en même temps mais ça y est très
prenante développer leurs pièces
ouais c'est assez agressive comme
ouverture c est sûr on est toujours là
ça existe quelque chose tout à fait ça
on peut pas reprendre du pied puisque le
flou bloque donc en fait on fait rock et
leur menace de reprendre des quatre avec
un très fort centre de bio et on aura du
mal avec une noire sortir le cabri g8
donc savoir que rock il faut pas prendre
en général comme perdue tam quelques
semaines a au contraire il faut savoir
quel rock ça fait partie de
développement c'est très important que
la tournée du père noël et tout rentrait
j'ai donc bien sûr c'est pas une fois
défensivement au contraire ça peut être
agressive progressif en plus aux menaces
en faisant recombinantes en reprenant
des jeunes comédiens là ils ont fêté
trois donc là les noirs jouent des trois
qui est un coup logique aussi une idée
c'est de pas prendre ces trois pour ne
pas permettre qu'un libéré plus tard de
sortie c'est à dire vois rien de
principal cette reprise sur ses trois
médailles vont faire connaître voir s'il
prend sur ses trois sur un commentaire
on peut faire tomber trois ils sont
jeunes en b3 alors l'idée c'est qu'on a
une batterie ici et on attaque le club
et donc il faut faire ici en général par
exemple d'un merci alors il faut
protéger avec la dame ou g5 ça c'est la
théorie et on attaque comme la dame
n'est pas trop partir parce qu'ils y
arrivent cette entreprise il doit rester
de l'expansion fait six morts
et là on va reprendre car les c3 par
exemple maintenant on reprend voilà le
cavalier avec un temps et toutes les
sorties de gwen et ils ont perdu
tellement de pions mais spécialement ils
ont distribué mais ils ont repris mi
temps avec tempo avec arias et 3 ses
pions donc c'était ça il va d'ailleurs
avoir une principale tout à fait donc
les noirs apparemment il voulait pas
rentrer 1 ça donc ils ont joué des trois
que notre coup l'idée on laisse le pion
c3 donc sans gêne le piolet construction
où il le fou peut-être qu'ils vous
pourrez également potentiellement sortir
de bd au plus tard pour contrôler grande
diagonale à savoir si toujours bien
contre les diagonales comme çà et là
avec ses trois ils sont dix mètres ont
bloqué ses propres pièces on l'a pas
prendre en bloc voilà donc ça c'est
normal donc ici les blancs jouent quand
même beaucoup d'hommes b3 qui est
logique on sort la dame gain de temps on
se moque d'eux puisse obtenu trois
passes que sont les noirs peuvent pas
les protéger on lui pour le prendre à
plus tard oui attaque tout de suite dans
le ciel c'est vraiment aller
maintenant on est agressé le roi prendre
il est dans le centre une fois que la
sortie lecavalier sera trop tard il va
faire rocha et après si on a distribué
trois pions en parts égales et trois
pelles tout de suite donc voilà il faut
tout casser le roy on n'a pas tant de
mettre de prendre les pieds de
l'adversaire donc ici d'un v6 les noirs
des sorts alors d'or d'un petit parce
qu'il veut sans doute sortir l'autre
cavalli sur la case de cette aire
protégée
7 il protège ici le pion évidemment est
une fête qui était attaqué par cette
batterie ou dame très dangereux très
dangereux
donc là les blancs continuent leur leur
attaque maintenant parce que ils
essaient de mettre les noirs sous une
pression maximale dont qui joue le
couple 5 ans 10 ans mais si les noirs
prennent ici c'est très bon puisque ma
tour peut sortir tout de suite face aux
cavaliers prendre 5
évidemment les blancs joué tour avec
gain de temps sur le cavalier l'atout
ressorti la safer concrètement derrière
parce qu'il y aura des six forcé est
enlevé cinq par exemple si on joue par
exemple effective dans le b 5 échecs et
le fouet berlin 4 l je prends un coup de
fouet je prendrai peut-être d'abord le
cavalier est arrivé la même chose et
après je prends le fond
donc ça perd une pièce donc
c'est pas bon donc il faut pas prendre
évidemment ce pion 5 dont des walis des
scènes agressé tout en attaque et on
t'envoie ce que ça vous permet de gagner
du temps duquel les noirs sont obligés
sur encore et encore c'est défendre et
placer les pièces de cet objet si ce
donc là andersen joue le coutour eu un
coût logis je sors la tour maintenant je
suis dernièrement turin
donc si dès que les noirs jouent des 6
et je peux prendre avec échec non c'est
pas bon donc les noirs jouent un coup
très logique câble et j'ai eu cette voie
là prépare le petit rock mais une pièce
en plus vis-à-vis le tour c'est mieux
pour protéger leurs droits
c'est très très logiquement hélas
andersen joue le coup normal aussi x 3 x
3 alors l'idée de foix iii c'est comme
si les noirs font petit rock et bien le
cas mais le set est presque plus est
puisqu'il ya là pour vous qui serait
derrière et se fous rires des contrôles
une belle diagonale on empêche la javel
et noir de jouer des six oui et donc on
empêche ce fou de sortir oui avons vu
que les noirs n'ont pas prêt sur ces
trois ça n'a pas ouvert finalement la
candidature si on place maintenant aux
réseaux ça sert à rien de rien donc il
faut placer sur les diagonales libre les
fous pas sûr competo et c'est donc ici
par contre les noirs ils sont joués un
coup à cette auto c'est à dire et même
mauvais oui il est là le nord sur une
fois parce qu'ils auraient quand même
dur oui il aurait dû effectivement le
correct il était temps de rock et donc
ça s'est arrêté hier pour vous aussi
parce que voilà que nous avons cette
fois 6000 fr rockets vous avez le roi
dans le centre il faut le faire après
parfois c'est trop tard sans doute le
lait blanc he suivi par tour aux 3 par
exemple
mais c'est par un doublement futur des
tours et préparant la reprise du pion
des trois en attaquant la dame qui ont
regagné du temps et potentiellement
septembre après fr transferts bien sûr
sûr j'ai trois sur trois pour attaquer
le roi noir bien sûr enfin ce serait une
autre partie là les noirs ont joué le
coup b5
on m'en avait dit ce fou a du mal à
sortir donc il joue b5 avec l'idée
pourquoi pas plus tarder c'est de sortir
souvent des beats et
uturbey 8 éventuellement ce qui se passe
très souvent quand l'adversaire en fait
quand l'adversaire ou s'écrit fait
quelque chose par exemple et vous
sentait très mal une réponse hippiques
c'est respectifs y ait quelque chose ça
c'est vraiment il faut pas oublier parce
que fo typique des débutants c'est il
veut pardonner le matériel il faut
donner trop content surtout ça et il
faut pas lâcher
il faut savoir donner ça c'est un très
très bon système mais là c'était un peu
exagéré partie parce que ça a porté
fruit quand on a pris du matériel faut
savoir le rendre de mourir asphyxiés je
pense les noirs c'est qu'il voulait
faire avec ses poupées 5070 je voudrais
donner un pion mais je vais développer m
qui va rentrer directement dans les
choux gras cette tour de 8 et c'est donc
au revoir c'est que c'est passé dans le
premier cinq donc donc là c'est logique
on prend pas du tout évidemment parce
que si on avait pris du fou on peu avant
le problème puisque tour des 8 et le
fouet ses idées noires et puis en plus
cela tombe bien le protège bessette on
pourra jouer au foot 17 éventuellement
une fois huit derrière où aller car ce
genre de choses ça le développement du
coup les pièces arrivent dans le jour
voilà donc on joue plutôt d'armes
prohibées 5 voilà on n'a pas peur
surtout v8 puisqu'ils vont reviennent
tout simplement sur 1,4 c'était la
partie
elle est bien placé la dame regardez par
exemple maintenant sur petit rock ça
marche plus oui c'est puisque on
prendrait le cabillaud set et après car
les plans cavaliers le fou à 5 n'est
plus protégé ça empêche petit rock donc
ça explique le coup suivant des noirs
foulée 6 voilà pour préparer maintenant
effectivement un petit rôle
donc petit rock est devenu une sorte de
rêve qu'elle pour l'instant réalisé donc
il faut il faut c'est pour ça faussaire
l'europe quand vous pouvez pas amener la
situation jusqu'à une telle situation
critique donc là des recettes sort son
sa dernière pièce finalement oui le
câble et b d2 et or là il était encore
temps pour le noir de rock et très
certainement il aurait fallu rockets
avec une partie encore jouable et là il
choisit de
fu 17 alors encore une faute de très
important et surtout pas répéter gros
qu'aient il faut faire rocker on s'est
vraiment mis en examen mais ça ne veut
pas toujours pas fait le rocky horror
dès maintenant car il y en a quatre et
c'est déjà trop tard pour ok parce que
si on rock
maintenant on a un problème puisque les
blancs peuvent tout simplement je
prendre en d3 et lecavalier au cas de
menace de bouger avec un impact sur la
dame il ya aussi la possibilité de
prendre un set suivi de d'impression
enfin voilà ça commence déjà à être
pénible donc parce que s'ils auraient
marqué les bleus ont reçu cette position
rien qu'en sacrifiant ainsi le pion
finalement c'est vraiment largement
comprendre c'est parce que
on n'a pas sacrifié finalement grand
chose hélas si on reprend sur des trois
déjà mais matériellement on a plus de
retard on a beaucoup meilleur placement
des pièces meilleure activité qu'elle
est noire et les découvertes mercredi et
ça ça donne un avantage décisif
ça devient pénible ardemment 6,5 tarifs
5 de la part des noirs peut-être parce
que maintenant les alors ça c'est un
coup c'est un coût qui est déjà une
faute peut-être encore même l'europe
même si tu étais c'était chaud c'était
sans doute le meilleur que je jouais
toujours mais il joue encore 2005 donc
là c'est trop c'est ça devient trop tard
puisque après faut prendre des trois
voit pas trop ce que fait la dame là et
la menace ses cavaliers des six échecs
et la dame est perdu à cause de la
découverte
et si les noirs fondre au petit rock ici
c'est la même chose cavaliers de l'autre
côté f6 et chez droit et le fou prend la
dame donc j'ai pas que les noirs il vaut
mieux qu'elles peuvent pas faire
roquettes du coup uniquement delà il se
rend compte que la dame ne pouvoir
rester sur cette place ça c'était comme
une langue que là encore une
chose à retenir pour les débutants il
faut pas jouer placé aussi la dame dans
le centre où il est très facilement
attaquable exemple exactement la dame
finalement il n'y a pas de bouc ans on
appelle ça car il n'y a pas de place et
les pièces qui se dirigent tout le temps
parce qu'ils ne trouvent pas une pom
placer tout en attaque et alors notez
qu'un coup ici comme même dame g4 on
ferait quand même échec et après puis on
prend regardez c'est la dame a quatre
qui prend la dame voyez ça s'appelle un
déchet que la découverte
je fais une découverte ici en faisant
échec sur tout ce que je fais c'est que
je permets à la dame un cadre de prendre
donc il faut jouer des matchs 5 seul
coup quasiment qui restait à ou noirs et
là maintenant c'est l'heure pour
andersen dû sacrifier quand même parce
qu'on profite maintenant du fait que la
tour est en face du roi échec avec
fourchette sur la dame donc ça oblige
les noirs et les colonnes et l'idée
c'est qu'on veut reprendre ici en 6 en
ouvrant la colonne de la tour donc très
important dans les ouvertures aussi ça
cette notion a regardé puis on prend m6
et à londres en m6 a remarqué ils font
ça aussi parce que si nous les noirs
enfin il pourrait faire rock et après et
comme je disais parfois davantage
peuvent disparaître
ce n'est pas non plus éternel donc il
faut vraiment bien saisir le moment
critique et osé quelques barbouzes elle
calculée en même temps des mots
d'anglais
par exemple le roi reste vraiment dans
le centre alors qu'ils attaquaient un
tour mais la pression la fois 3 met la
pression tout est bien placé pour g8 de
la part des noirs alors avec un défi
j'attaque g2 puis j'ai l'espoir qu'avec
le fou bessette ici je peux créer des
menaces
oui en plus c est à 9,3 donc
menaces aussi évidemment d'en prendre
cavaliers puisque le pion ne peut pas
reprendre à cause de la banque jamie
mais il ya une attaque ici et regardez
ce que fait un gars entre tranquillement
bien c'est vraiment un excellent tour à
d il ramène la dernière pièce
tranquillement il écoute prend le mont
cavaliers n'y a pas de problème et
regardez alors ça c'est assez
exceptionnel quand même voilà ces
superbes avoir des nerfs continue aussi
tranquille comme si de rien n'était
laissé les emprises un peu c'est un
match qui est menacée après prise
bien sûr là les doigts reprennent le
cavalier là c'est la dernière chose il y
avait peut-être une combinaison pour les
noirs ici c'est donc peut-être de
prendre en g2 pour profiter du fait que
si le roi noix les noix reprennent on
pourrait être bloquée comme ça ce genre
de choses en attaque avec le fou mais
voilà il a fait d'emprunt f3 et là
regardez la très belle combinaison comme
il fallait pas rater ça tout reprend
échec et son adversaire regardez
maintenant trois échecs que faire
regarder si on vient ensuite évidemment
le fou ici ferait un échec dont il
suffirait d'enlever le tour par exemple
ici et la dame ait perdu son compte et
qui est sans doute mat donc oui il a
fait cavalier prend tour et là regardez
alors là c'est super ballon c'est la
combinaison qu'il faut connaître siècle
voit la fin du siècle de l'époque dont
vous regardez ses superbes dame prend 17
sacrifice de dames énorme donc là
l'adversaire a repris la barre il a
regardé la tour est attaqué en d1 il ya
presque plus de pièces et plus 2 ou 3
pièces pour le regarder ces superbes
fouet f5 échec au regard des doubles
échecs du fou et de la tour donc on peut
pas prendre la tour puisque le fou
ferait chez le roi fait toujours échec
on peut pas prendre le fou puisque la
tour dont contient double échec on n'a
pas le choix et qu'il faudra déplacer le
roi
il n'y a pas d'autres informations alors
s'il est noir venait sur la case c6 et
rsa des trios limmat
youri maths en 17 ans née le roi ne peut
plus bouger en c5 half où on avait 5 et
le fou 17 est protégé par la tour donc
c'est pas possible il reste le seul
autre coup c'est roy 1,8 et là tout
simplement fou 17
l'adversaire a joué roi et fuite mais
roi des huit auraient mené à la même
chose puisque à la maintenance et ça
c'est vraiment un couple julien courbet
faut prendre cet échec et mat donc
superbe les blancs sont un coup du mat
ils sont quasiment à eux aussi ils ont
une tour emprise mais c'est bien les
noirs qui sont matt c'est superbe
voilà donc faut pas prendre trop de
pièces faut pas jouer trop de fois la
même pièce il faut donc être extrêmement
prudent et donc retenir axel de ps c'est
quelque chose d'important nos échecs il
faut être vu activement développé les
pièces placées sur les ponts gaz
agresser l'adversaire
tout à fait si vous êtes menacé faire
les contres menace être agressive active
wallace et qui compte deux échecs et se
développer surtout comme vous l'avez vu
vite sinon on est vite maintenant on va
voir une 2 de la deuxième partie qui
s'appelle l'immortel qui est très bien
aussi donc imaginer c'est encore plus
belle que celle ci combien toi voilà
elle est aussi la meilleure c'est
toujours un verset non regardez moi ça
me 4,5 alors cette fois il joue ce qu'on
appelle un gambit du roi des nèfles
car ici on sacrifie un pion tour pareil
dans l'idée de gagner du temps si on
prend fou c4 qui est une variante
anciennes
les noirs font échec alors regardez on
ne peut pas sur échec je peux pas jouer
j'ai trois parce que sinon simplement
les noirs prendre un g3 y en a des
soucis donc au jour iphone donc là on se
dérobe volontairement vous allez voir
l'idée c'est que les noirs contre
attaque sur le fous pareils les noirs
veut essayer de gagner du temps en fait
c'est oui c'est à l'époque c'était
vraiment le tempo un oui c'est à
l'époque il fallait qu'un but est très
très à la mode ont même joué la gambie
il s'est très facilement
d'ailleurs ça m'étonnait j'ai découvert
que c'est toi rien exactement était
jouée par short gaspard en tailleur mais
dans une partie rapide à 93 ans et ça va
assez étonné parce que en général ne
voit pas trop les gambi tags ou
l'angoissé niveau là est d'ailleurs ses
shorts cavaliers à cleveland contre 15
par an donc voilà finalement ça chez
vous quand même alors les noirs se
développe sa c5 qu'ils attaquent le qumi
4 ici les blancs se développe en
attaquant la dame ta machine nice alors
l'idée d'un maxi c'est qu'on protège le
pion f4 ce qu'on veut pas que les blancs
ajouté cap est fou preuve quatre avec
gain de temps comme ça il ya un petit
oeil sur ce pion donc des trois de la
part des blancs voilà on commence à
mettre aussi le fou mais en fait on
commence à taper sur f4 qu'elle lâche 5
/ protection du pion est un peu c'est
une menace
une bête et fourchettes sur g3 on menace
aussi cavale et j'ai trois échecs
fourchette et s'il est blanc reprennent
on peut faire d'emprunt tour donc alors
coups étranges là ici d'andersen
cavaliere car c'est un protège comme les
trois en même temps donc on empêche les
g3 oui mais il vit
la case f5 en fait donc comme ça il va
rentrer avec lecavalier
donc ça c'est en défensive agressive
d'objets cinq attaques
le cavalier et là on comprend pourquoi
il a fait aussi des salaires c'est là
qu'est en fait ils attaquent de ps
première idée pourquoi tu as l'air parce
qu'elle parle on voit la première fois
on s'est dit mais il faut juste croire
avec des cinqueterre
voilà les faits le bien on voit que le
foot en l'air en fait et dans ce petit
goût comme g5 à l'air de gagner une
pièce 9,5 obligatoire que l'ex n empêche
évidemment voilà on bloque à la faune
sauvegarde lecavalier et en plus on
empêche d'un pointu mais là on ne peut
pas finir mon travail parce qu'il y aura
toujours h4 on n'a pas peur du g6 parce
que dans ce cas-là h4 et des cloud a
même lancé la dame bouge et on pourra
enlever facilement plus facilement donc
allée f 5 c6 et là j'ai quatre alors ça
sert alors ça c'est un joli coup l'idée
mais j'attaque le caillage cents contre
attaque ils m'attaquent le fou j'attaque
le cavalier on peut pas prendre en
passant parce que c'est connu on peut
mais on perdrait la dame est sûre donc
et le full piocher 4 il protégeait pas
encore une fois où vous voyez vous à
quel point cette a créé 6 mai
cette partie c'est très très agressive
pour mon attaque tout le monde personne
ne parle de réguler c'est tout le temps
de contrôler taxes et voilà c'est
vraiment très très joli c'est du jeu de
l'époque alors si les blancs les noirs
et prix en bessin et les blancs ont
repris en v5 avec l'idée de mettre la
tour en juin et donc avoir une colonne
ouverte ici potentiellement sur le roi
parce qu'il veut marquer il peut pas
faire grand roque après prix si on fait
ça parce que c'est trop couvert et si on
a donc surgi un navet colons ouverte
elle préfère donc le droit va rester pas
sécurisé donc allier m6 tongs et d'un
donc là voilà ça y est c'est l'idée
toujours un pied alors je menace je peut
menacer aussi dh 4 puisque le câble f5
protège h quatre années où va la dame
donc ce rejet c'est sûr j'ai six sapeurs
l'adami h4 et l'aveyron non s'il est
noir rouge et 6 assists et souhaitons
donc ici ses premiers singles donc on a
joué 7 va rentrer on a donné le flou les
saints n'ont donc sacrifice des docks
est dans l'air h théâtre attaque la dame
mais encore une fois on retrouve arrête
pour les mêmes principes les mêmes
c'était regarder la question noire où
ils sont victimes
il ya un an le 5 avril et donc est sorti
mais ça c'est très moche mais nous aussi
on n'est pas trop pour l'instant mais au
revoir que pour les blancs savoir les
plus riches voilà donc on n'a pas peur
de donner du matos qu'on dit donc ici h5
on continue à attaquer la dame dame g5
et regardez là le très jolies dames f3
et avec l'idée bien écoute c simple je
menace foucras f4 et la dame éprise au
grain il faut trouver une solution
il faut que la dame puisse sortir d'où
le pont et un pouce ce cavalier donc
forme ce calibre capable 15
exceptionnelle d'objets de revenus
angeli alors ça c'est important c'est
donc là ça veut dire que les blancs
oblige il est noir a à mon nom seulement
à ne pas se développer
oui mais en tribune revenir même les
rares pièces qui est assorti il revient
sur les quinze de départ malviennes déjà
à retenir qu'il faut jamais revenir sur
le quinze de départ mais là il ya plus
de choix
mais sinon ça a considéré comme un
désastre parce que revenir sur la tasse
dons
donc la regarder 1 2 3 maintenant quatre
avec foucault f4 il faut jouer la no 4
temps de développement
on a donné quoi une pièce en termes de
pions on a même un pion on a récupéré
qui ont donc on a un équivalent de deux
pions avec quatre temps de développement
bientôt 5
ça veut dire que c'est quasiment
al'avantage des blondes donc là malgré
le matériel de moins vraiment toutes les
places et seront utiles il ya que la
dame qui est sorti en plus il a attaqué
encore une fois encore on comprend tout
de suite que cette partie n'est pas trop
duré regardez damev si ces erreurs des
comme les blancs n'ont pas peur d'en
prendre b2 tout simplement cavalli c3 je
sors la dernière pièce et je menace coib
sans doute devenir des dessins des cinq
avec des échecs possible et des choses
comme ça il faut faire très attention
fou c'est 5 de la place des noirs donc
la part des la torture j en attaque lato
jeune lycéenne de gagner du temps alors
les blancs pourraient même envisager de
faire des d4 ou des choses comme ça mais
mais encore mieux oui c'est là qu'on
voit que la puissance au raz des toutes
les pièces sorties andersen va revoir en
direct il y va avec quatre des cinq dans
cette partie mortels très joli coup les
noirs se libère je peux prendre b2 qui
attaquent à tours et à saint yves à 3
fois la tour est attaqué et là regardez
ce que fait andersen cavale et s'éteint
en fout du wifu d66 et superbe food et 6
maintenant s'il est noir prend 7 ci
accepte avec notamment 7 s'écrit fils
c'est d'autos ont fait roi eux deux et
la tour g1 attaque la dame s'il prend
par hasard d'un bien par exemple là il
va recevoir directement maths et la
regarder y aurait dans ce cas là qu'à
l'étranger cet échec au rang regardez
tous les six ont contre toutes les cases
donc on est obligé de venir sur la case
ih six des huit lots regardez maintenant
et j'ai eu le c7 et matt maths parce
qu'on ne peut pas venir à 8 quand même
pas payer à la dame c avec trois points
c'est non donc c'est très joli
donc on peut pas prendre la tour donc il
prend l'autre tour notre famille
il fait [ __ ] à tours pour garder la
darbella contrôle du du pion je sais ce
qu'on fout été attaqués de sa part 6 et
donc voilà donc d'où l'idée maintenant
d'anderson de jouer le coup superbe qui
avait sans doute pas prévu sur
l'adversaire ou cinq ans très joli on
l'est à tour un bonheur aussi tranquille
ça c'est l'idée simplement c'est
justement d'empêcher leur m2 contre
oyonnax et aux menaces mat très vite ici
mais comme tout à l'heure on a même eu
la même idée pouces à 7 avant la fin car
les prends ici suis rodé 8 et matt ans
et 7
donc que faire pas évident de façon sans
compter que la dame pourrait venir aussi
henri vii
donc il prend quand même qu'il a mis en
échec comme on dit souvent de cheikh
quitte à mourir autant mourir le ventre
plein si l'adversaire se trompe je re -
du matériel alors au jour à o2 tout
simplement
on a par ailleurs la menace est toujours
là on a donné du matériel cavaliers
assises de la part des noirs l'idée
d'essayer de contrôler la casse et 7
pour éviter le match qu'on a cité est
quand même cavalier prendrait sept quand
même échec échec roi il peut pas bouger
sur les cases m'en fous donc obligés de
venir du terroir derrière c'est
exceptionnel très jolie dame échec quand
même l'idée c'est que ce cavalier g8
peut pas contrôler la case et fils et la
case de sept puisque là ils obligés de
prendre et on fait pas mates ans et 7
mais de l'autre côté recettes
regardez un deux trois pièces pour les
blancs contre 1 2 3 4 5 6 est nulle ou
noir ils ont dans mes deux tours on peut
me sens fait ça c'est vraiment
exceptionnel
le service permet d'autant plus méritée
voilà matin avec trois pièces en plein
centre de l'échiquier
on donne la dame à la fin voyez
l'importance du développement e
les blancs tout miser sur le
développement donc c'est à connaître
aujourd'hui le jeu moderne c'est plus
tout à fait ça parce que justement les
joueurs sont mieux préparés ils évitent
de se laisser distancer dès l'ouverture
qui sont ils font plus attention mais à
l'époque c'était un grand de voir des
partis comme ça oui sinon 46 aujourd'hui
c'est plus ça ça veut dire qu'elle
n'avait que peu à distribuer tellement
pièce parce que oui quelque part ce
n'était pas tout à fait correct mais
c'est l'adversaire qui est qu'ils se
trompent et quelque part mais c'est sûr
que vous serez initiative ça reste
aujourd'hui aussi c'est ce qu'ont fait
ton temps on s'écrit mais on s'écrit
fait peut-être un type au moins on sait
que c'est une qualité on voit là une
pièce mais on va rarement jusqu'à ses
crédos tout ça ça arrive ça arrive mais
avec les calculs concrets précise le
temps mais au passé c'est vrai il va
lancer le ps pour la gauche à droite
parfois pas forcément avoir calculé
jusqu'à vous unités maths en tout cas
retenu la leçon
quand vous avez vu la deux parties qui
sont effectivement essentiel à apprendre
à connaître pour bien comprendre
l'essence du jeu d'échecs la puissance
des pièces les attaques de maths prime
est dans l'ouverture comme vous ne le
voir amélie très important développé
très vite ces pièces et des travaux sans
entraves on sait pas pas hésité à donner
du matériel à lâcher du matériel si
l'adversaire veut prendre des pions
belsele prendre les pions rauque et
développer vos pièces et si vous jouez
précis vous allez le récupère en général
plus que ce que vous avez investi
c'est le principe merci nino pour cette
superbe leçon sur cette ve partie
fondamentale à connaître très bien tu en
voilà à très bientôt
merci
[Musique]